good morning Millennials
good morning Millennials we are just so
low energy like I just I don't know if I
have it in me I don't I'll make myself
have it in me but I currently don't have
it in me I am so tired I'm so tired and
I'm like emotionally drained because
when I woke up I rolled over and watched
a leak he'll go on the Today show and to
be honest I didn't really know like what
she was about and was such an inspiring
interview with Maria Shriver like I
literally cried and now I'm just like
I'm beat
look me and Theo beat Tigs is here today
so it's really a special day of nephews
me chest I needed my emotional support
out of mom I didn't know he was coming
today but every time I wear the sweater
had come I like to surprise you with you
I don't know why it's like I don't want
Jackie to know because it's a precious
gift and then like the joy on your face
when you walk into a studio and see a
little bushy little tail it's like the
greatest thing that's what I saw I saw a
little tail going behind the set and
there's no great joy like the gift of
Theo
isn't it so crazy how we were just like
I think it was at my most beautiful in
like the last five years last night and
I literally look like I got hit by a
train today no it's crazy how that
happens first of all and second of all
yet last night I just took it all out of
me it's not even like we went hard or
anything no I like didn't even like
drink that much but it's just like
teetering around in your heels for six
hours will do that to a girl it's also a
workout cuz like you're elevated and
you're like sucking in and you're just
doing so many things all at once you're
standing up straight for that long we're
sitting up straight so describe the TPG
awards in one word lit lit no it really
was like a party honestly I just could I
kept like remembering that we were on an
aircraft carrier like we were literally
in a museum in a public like place
public property yep it was crazy
we were on the Hudson okay that's what's
so crazy we're on the intrepid the USS
Intrepid which is a warship that's now
retired and now is a museum for young
Steen's to visit on Memorial Day to pay
tribute to the troops who have served us
and Fleet Week and that's our TVG chose
to do the award show which was an
inspired choice I mean for a million
reasons one it's like such a monumental
like New York landmark to the plains of
a transportation of it all it's an
aircraft carrier it's the points guy
Awards and then three
the ship is docked on the Hudson and if
you watched our stories you know that
Chesley Sullenberger was the guest of
honor
Jackie's personal hero my personal hero
so we were on the Hudson with the man
who performed the miracle on the Hudson
and irony wasn't lost on I have to
believe that it's in Sully's Ryder to be
like if not on the Hudson not interested
you know greenroom needs one small
window with access to the Hudson because
you know our theory on the movie is that
they kind of made it seem like he had a
Hudson River fetish and he's really like
itching to land a plane on the Hudson
that's just the vibe they put out I
didn't think that I don't think it's
true but what was so crazy is that one
of the CEO of the parent company that
ended up acquiring the points guy is
this guy Rick and he was on that flight
he was seen sitting in seat 1d
and he was like I was ready to die and
lose just like talking about it and he
hasn't met Sully since that day yeah and
so he gave a brief speech just about
like what it was like to be on the plane
and think he was gonna die and like how
was I've changed afterwards and then
Sully came out and he had given Sully
the award and they like met for the
first time and it was just inspiring
also Sully had jokes cuz he was talking
about how Rick was in 1d so he was in
first class and he didn't get as wet as
the other passengers shut day and then
Sully went into his motivational speaker
average so that's what's just so funny
is like Hollywood has a way of like
churning these people out she was like
Salinas was a regular guy fighter pilot
you know and now he's literally a
motivational speaker he's Bruce Jenner
because he gave an amazing speech but I
know that he said it seven hundred times
before you know yes but he did he opened
like with jokes that were pertinent to
the event and then he went into his
speaking engagement which I'm was glad
to hear because I want to know what like
what Sully's telling people what are the
takeaways yeah from the flight and you
know what they're all really great and
he's just such a cutie I didn't even
tell you something so easy that happened
so since you know I went to the bathroom
and on our way out like I did a photo
shoot for her in front of one of the
aircraft marketers and a woman comes
behind me and was like by the way do you
know that that's the plane that John
McCain was in when he was shot down like
not that's not the exact plane but
that's the model and I was like oh my
god that's so cool thank you for letting
us know like snitch you should put that
in your Instagram caption if you post
this picture and then
like look again didn't she mention it
like a shade a little bit because I
think it was like short dresses with
your tits I'd write these thoughts in
front of an aircraft carrier maybe you
should know the history but what she
doesn't know is like we're pretty
respectful gals like we're not just your
regular run-of-the-mill
Instagram thoughts and I truly believe
it's what John McCain would have wanted
right
no I follow Mike and McCain on Instagram
and I know that's like that's just their
family center of the picture and be like
your dad would be proud amen
god bless america but and then I said to
Sameach I was like I think that's mrs.
Sullenberger and then Sully walked over
started talking to her and so we had to
flee the scene I definitely should think
she was being a little Shaddai but I was
here for it because like good to know
that mrs. Sullenberger has some Shaddai
in her well also other thing I was being
shady about aircraft carriers right of
course she is she is her husband's wife
there's a pot there's a lid for every
pot honestly what I loved about just
like having access to like the points
guy and just like being his friend is
like the backstage area I saw some some
cute moments I saw mrs. Sullenberger
asked for a photo with Adam Rippon cute
very cute and I just saw like lots of
things I was like loving it honestly
like I've never like presented an award
I never even like spoke at a podium I
felt so short the podium was so little I
mean so big we are so short like I felt
so short when I was wearing my dress and
I was looking in the mirror and I was
like this dress when you hold it on it's
tiny it's tiny there's no me it's very
literally a piece of paper and it's like
I put it on and still I have no legs
like my legs are so short and that's
like really why being a supermodel like
is awesome because the wife likes for
days and I never feei never care about
being short or think about it but I
really just felt short in that dress
because it's like where are my legs
bless you this dress would be all eggs
I'm Olivia culpo
oh my god of course it's omni's yeah no
the knees like now that I'm like a
skinny person and I what show my knees
like my knees are problematic any darker
than my regular leg I think we have like
genetically bad knee I think so too
like just not know be very Jewish knees
not cute because it's not just like the
skin and the bone on the knee it's like
the skin the bone and then like the side
part the flesh on the inside yeah very
fleshy
and then sometimes you get like a cap on
top okay let's run through the night
let's run through that okay he went to
cocktail hour but we get to tip out
early for a mean agree with Sully right
and bebe Rexha photos to come soon I'm
so excited to see the my pictures with
Sully I have some on my phone but
they're not premium and you guys deserve
only the back before actually seeing her
perform we went in to be Brett says I
mean green she was so nice and so cool
that she was just like worried about how
she looked in the photos but she looked
so cute and just like loved her her vibe
but wasn't intimidated at all which is
like really easy to be when you walked
into like a room with a celebrity their
bodyguard their makeup artist their hair
artists their assistant like their whole
team and then it's like she was just so
cool I loved her she was really cool I
really loved her I want to be her friend
no michi we'll talk about the that's the
problem with me because if you're
showing up for a meet-and-greet
you're like a leader ready in the sand
zone I was fine with that for Sully all
I said is hello Sully I'm a big fan of
your work I didn't even like try to
schmooze you know cuz I'm not a fan of
Sully but if I want to be a friend of
bebe you can't cheer for the new one
like silly is at the level where he
can't have friends like Emily only has
admirers and in what world would Sully
and I be friends like never never sorry
so we went to meet we also walk the red
carpet and you know you don't see those
pictures like immediately you probably
just this morning I'm like you're gonna
die like we are the skinniest most tan
most beautiful girls in the world like
rock stars no like I don't even know
what to do because there's so many photo
options and that's just not something
I'm used to I'm not one of those girls
gonna have to do a side I think no no I
think I'm gonna have to do multiple
poses on Claude within a job girl with
no job and like a couple on the toes and
a couple on pup oh the ones of us will
put on the toes yeah solo solo okay so
after the meet and greets which were
just so great we sounded at our with
such a great table it's not even really
hooked us up with a great meet a better
table than TPG like in terms of
placement and I think maybe in terms of
talent too because I got to hand select
all the people sitting at our table and
it was family Ben Heather and the
stallion and she was to being so funny
like I just like could sit and I could
talk about other people with Heather
forever here's like everything Heather
says like makes me laugh and it's like
sometimes she's not even making a joke
and I laugh you know that must be
frustrating when you say something and
you're serious but she's like what'd we
say about Kevin Hart she's like
physically funny
like the way she talks reacts and uses
her hands Simon Huck and Phil were at
our table my friend Eric and John it was
just such a great night and the actual
Awards like I was some of them were like
a little beyond my knowledge I don't
know what a mid-tier credit card is so
I couldn't whatever but the awards for
like best just airline loyalty program
it was like American advantage United
Mileage JetBlue true true blue and tells
the sky and I personally like invest so
much financial resources and just my
time and my energy into Delta SkyMiles
so for them to have won the award which
they did was like so great for me like
if they hadn't won like I really would
have had to reevaluate everything
because one thing I know for sure is
that the awards were voted on by his
readers and every award show is rigged
but I don't believe that the TPG Awards
rigged they were really fan voted so the
fact that everyone agrees with me that
Delta SkyMiles is the best rewards
program like I felt really good about
okay great because if it had been
something else I might have had to like
disperse my eggs from the one basket but
now I can carry on do you think Theo has
the the Jewish knee honestly he's got
like supermodel eggs I think he might be
related to Olivia culpo I don't want to
jinx it and I don't even uh anyways we
had an amazing table we worked really
hard for it cuz we were hooting and
hollering oh you know and it was really
like a roller coaster because there was
a Nobel Peace Prize winner I forgot her
name she does an amazing work for women
in Liberia
she was just amazed she stole the show
she gave Sally a run for his money no no
I would say I enjoyed her speech a
little bit more than Sully's because
hers was more like on the cuff I enjoyed
her speech more than Sully's but between
Rick and Sully
and the holes and I like Joe gage I
don't know well she was this activist
from my beer as she's won a Nobel Peace
Prize she was wearing the cutest dress
she was making so many jokes about
coming to America and meeting Brian and
like learning about the gay community
she was so funny and then there was also
like hysterical highs with like um
kimchi from RuPaul's Drag Race
right who's saying I drove all night by
Celine Dion which is just my favorite
song also as an audience member a
hysterical hi was you're a bit of Santa
oh I mean I would agree but I wasn't
there for it it was so funny thank you
we were crying ideally could laugh
regardless of what your mouth which we
would have done but we were dying well
it's very difficult for me because like
I'm like a I'm a comedian but I put the
air quotes just because I've only ever
performed in front of people who know my
work and like get my references and love
me you've never
like win over an audience great or like
being an audience of like businessmen
who have like no idea like when Ramona
Singer is you know it was bigwig season
it was big season and I feel like I can
talk a lot just about the treacherous
and I said travel but I also don't want
to offend the people and honestly the
moment like I had all these plans and I
went out there and it like it was I just
lost control but in a good way and I had
a really good time I feel like was
really good practice it was and it was
really funny everyone really enjoyed it
the only regret I have of the night it's
like I really don't felt I don't feel
like I networked enough with the bigwigs
like I didn't leave there with any
SkyMiles
any Starwood points I have nothing to
show no I completely agree you know but
it's like I'm me and Jackie and how they
were joking like we're cheering so much
like we're just being such good audience
members like where are the points no
it's like they announced every nominee
and gave people the opportunity to cheer
and like really not a lot of people did
except for us and the only thing I would
change about the event is like the more
you cheer for a nominee you get you
should get like started you should get
points with Marriott Rewards if you're
cheering for their nomination totally I
know you've never benefited from them
ever I will recommend to tbj I'll see
what he says
okay don't do I haven't opened my gift
bag yet so maybe there's something in
there I'm gonna have enough my gets
better Samsonite luggage I know which I
was really jazzed about and I was like
rolling out of the event and I felt like
Margo I felt like a flight attendant in
the heels and might like really oh my
god that is histor that's what I said
too honestly it was such a cool event
and then the bebe Rexha of it all oh my
god
Rockstar what a rockstar I didn't
realize how many songs I knew a person I
can't believe she sings like my actual
favorite song ever and when me and dad
started dating it was like our favorite
song take me home I know what was that
other David Guetta song she sang hey
mama
me Mom a know me young man and then
obviously to beat myself in all right
that's what my therapist says what was
that one oh that's what my therapist
said she performed it at the everything
she is an amazing voice like I was
really shocked cuz you know what I was
saying tomorrow it's like before I
became really like a Stan of hers and
familiar with her work and you just see
her on a red carpet she unfortunately
just due to the similarities in the way
they look it's compared anything a lot
to Rita Ora
who is a talentless hack and then you
just think oh by association they have
the same haircut and they have like a
lot of glitz and glam and
outfits and you think overeat uh lyrics
is also a terrible no an amazing voice
every song is banger and she writes all
of her own songs and the the it wasn't
her usual concert she was like you she
was proud to turn the room it wasn't a
room of her fans well I can imagine it's
hard I'm when you're when you play like
arenas and award shows to do a corporate
event and at first like I mean we were
like turning up but I don't think she
knew like that she was about to perform
for like the turnt crowd ya know she
also had to be a bit of a stand-up
comedian like in between sets like just
making jokes and making everyone feel
comfortable and she did an amazing job
so like I am if I ever had any doubts
about bebe Rexha which I didn't but if I
did gone I look forward to seeing her
and also she said she was a mom because
she had a dog and then then she really
likes tell your heart yeah yeah okay
also like I was like waddling around the
place I had two pairs of shoes like I
had purchased four pairs of shoes yes
you're in one yesterday for a girl who
never I shoes ever
especially here with no shoes I have two
shoes from although so like a safe
investment and then two shoes from
shifts SCH you t'see and obviously ends
up going with the most uncomfortable but
the most expensive and glamorous pair
but I know myself like I was running the
shoes around the house just like
gathering my things and I was dying so I
ended up bringing two pairs and like
walking around the platforms between the
carpet and my work events in the in the
ships ones but it really made me
appreciate quality well made shoes well
that's the thing about Shutts are very
similar to one of our favorite brands
that we talk about em Jamie because it's
they're made with the same leather and
in the same factories is like the most
designer and luxury brands but they're
at a more affordable price and they have
more updated style yep um we've spoken
about em Jamie before and by the way
when I dropped bought my dress for the
night at Bloomingdale's they sell em
Jamie at Bloomingdale's have this cute
little booth that is so prestigious I'm
so glad to know about em Jamie now I
know I wear my sneakers everywhere cuz
not only do they have laces but they're
also like thick enough and chunky enough
that I can find my foot in at the
airport they're the best airport too and
if you're a new listener or you didn't
take us up on it
last time you should head to MGM e-comm
go see for yourself how amazing these
shoes are at MGM e.com / toast for $50
off your first pair that's letters mg
EMI dot-com / toast for $50 for your
first pair M Jimmy calm / toast em Jimmy
Italian luxury may the old way sold the
new way I can't recommend welfare
honestly I'm gonna go - MJ me calm
Sascha chose today and you're gonna use
code ah yes I get $50 half that's a lot
of money I know also I've been cleaning
out my closet and I do need a little bit
more of more luxury sneakers because
really I love wearing you know white
sneakers from Target nurse I'm wearing
Air Force Ones
but they're really like all of my shoes
are so sad looking I was gonna say
they're almost disposable they're
disposable and I feel like MJ me
accomplished Lee is the same look but
they're they have longevity well I also
like now that I have this big fancy
closet I am like wanting to decorate it
with beautiful shoes right even though I
bought those all those shoes which I
will never wear they look good in my
closet no that's also a thing like
sometimes I get spy shoes because
they're just so beautiful it's like a
piece of art but I'm never gonna wear
them ever
I need to go through my closets it's
okay I'm sorry I have to discuss the
precious gem of a man in my lap okay but
don't jinx anything don't discuss him
without chasing him and you must stop
staring at your phone Oh am i doing a
bad job okay click thank you it's off oh
you know what else was there last night
pedra and loved her and they introduced
her it's reality star and mortician and
businesswoman of course entrepreneur
lawyer lawyer also she loved my dress
she said something to me I loved her
dress and I asked where I was from
because it's the right color for
Olivia's wedding she told me was from
Saks I forget the name but I wrote it
down okay we'll go back to Saks they
ain't good with us you didn't mean good
with us I'll try it again yeah baby they
apologized as long as they sent a car
and they fulfill my rider I'll be there
ok ok you guys without further ado me
and my pimple want to deliver the fast 5
story is that you need to know before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast ok some really exciting
into news that I didn't think I needed
but it's the news that I need you always
need it Jackie come on Kevin Hart is a
fish
hosting the 2019 Oscars in tune in tune
Wow
I thought just when you think you've
written the oscars off which for me I
really I didn't even care who was
hosting I saw a notification some like
think pieces yesterday about how the
Oscars were having a really hard time
finding a host because no one wants to
do it it's a thankless job
no one's ever like wow that was an
amazing hosting job and they're just
like like so like it's so like dated and
like the hypocrisy in the room is like
so prevalent these days know that who
wants to be the face of that right and
if you're a comedian it's like your
jokes are on national TV it's just a
[ __ ] minefield yeah
offend someone I'm Emily that it's like
remember Chris Rock hosted and there was
literally not a single African American
actor nominated in like the top like six
categories the hypocrisy I can't so
maybe this bodes well for what the
nominee what we're gonna say look if
this is a reflection of the Intune level
that we're gonna see this year then
maybe maybe I want to be disappointed
here's what he said on Instagram for
years I've been asked if I would ever
host the Oscars and my answer was always
the same I said that it would be the
opportunity of a lifetime for me as a
comedian and that it will happen when
it's supposed to I'm so happy to say
that the day has finally come for me to
host the Oscars I am blown away simply
because this goal has this has been a
goal on my list for a long time to be
able to join the legendary list of host
set of grace that stage is unbelievable
I know my mom is smiling from ear here
right now I want to thank my family
friends fans for supporting me and
riding with me all this time you're
welcome I will be sure to make this
year's Oscars a special one I believe
you and I couldn't just say I love when
celebrities like feel humbled like I
feel like especially with Kevin Hart
like he's the the most probably the
biggest comedian of our generation just
in terms of like sales Tour money
tickets he was the head the most people
ever shower comedian right here the most
people ever show up for him at a Madison
ever comedian at Madison Square Garden
like show and precedent but the fact
that like he still gets excited like
that gets me excited that gets me
excited I never thought these words
would come out of my mouth but are you
ready I'm so excited for the Oscars yeah
it's gonna be just Kevin Hart stand up
and I haven't been like really excited
about the Oscars in terms of their hosts
probably since epic varlyn
we talk about Seth MacFarlane host
oscar's once this I think Seth
MacFarlane is a really underrated talent
like a virgin and people are like Family
Guy yeah for sure whatever
Ted [ __ ] yeah the manipulation of his
head
the manipulation of his voice to be
Peter Frampton what's his name Peter
Luger
what's Family Guy Peter creditor Griffin
I'm sorry thought it means big crab um
he's a big family manipulation of his
voice is like it's a testament to like
how crazy and talented and like how much
control he has over his voice and most
people don't even know that he that goes
in Torun sings and I saw him at cafe
Carlyle and I was just like living for
him and he's like so hot and I just love
him so uh and James Corden which is like
a puppet for for Hollywood like he did
like they said jump and he said how hot
and he does the Grammys he has he did he
do the Oscars yes
Oh cuz he sings to numerable yeah right
Oh also we are too young to appreciate
this but Hugh Jackman hosted the Oscars
and he opened with a musical number like
he was just singing the whole time was
that with Leamas I might have been the
era blame is which I never saw which now
I need to see because I'm gonna see Hugh
Jackman live on tour so excited um but
this is just another level of special no
no it really is and just thank you
Hollywood like finally feeling just
because I feel like if we if literally
the Oscars which you know they do all
the time had come to the show and been
like you guys are most into girls in the
world who would you want to see host
Oscars of Kevin Hart would be on that
list Kevin Hart would be on that list
Tiffany Haddish would be on that list no
I'm not this year but I don't think
she's I don't think she's like it's time
much it happened um honestly did a me
Schumer might be on my list I think she
would do a really funny job Amy Schumer
two years ago would have been on my list
right now you know I'm totally gonna buy
look cloud what's that she's coming over
the clothing line in partnership with
Saks and it's just it goes from size
like zero to 20 it's like an inclusive
whatever and it's just like she's like I
wanted to start a brand that was size
inclusive and that was comfortable like
that is me yeah cool I think it's weird
that's in partnership with Saks because
tax hasn't carried anything like a Bubba
size ten in 35 years no but good it's an
in tune move I'm all here for everyone
turning it around you know if the Oscars
can do it so can you do good luck make
your own Jackie O line with any brand
company shoe store who do you think
would be the best
partner for the Jackie O Brad for
clothing yeah miss keen oh yeah Wow my
answer is so different well obviously
you would think ASOS but I think I would
do more of like a QVC oh for sure
because I really think Lisa Rinna's
dusters are super cute and they're like
affordable and so comfortable in there
but definitely well-made well that's the
like I wouldn't want it to be super
high-end so I'd have to be like mosquito
and H&M I'd want in on that yeah I'm on
that price point and that style and that
quality yeah yeah anyways are you ready
for the next story please cardi B says
she and offset are not together and I
was so shocked cardi B and her husband
fellow rapper offset have split up she
said an Instagram post Tuesday night
quote I've been trying to work things
out with my baby's father for a hot
minute now we're really good friends and
were really good business partners but
things just have been working out
between us for a long time the Bronx
born rapper said in the video posted
early Wednesday New York Times quote and
it's nobody's fault I guess we just grew
out of love but we're not together
anymore she said before adding it might
take time to get a divorce I'm really
sad I'm really sad - I didn't see this
coming I feel like she's never been
better and more like full I can't say no
and live in the words I'm not saying I
thought her love tank was full totally I
think that like this baby really like
change their lives I think she loves
being a mom so much and I think she
loves having a family and I also think
she loves having a spouse who's like
just as famous and rich as her so I'm
really shocked but she made it seem like
it was very amicable they're still
friends are gonna co-parent right I
think it's easy when you're both equally
rich famous and on the up and you both
have love and their giant jealousy right
there's no bad blood and you both want
the best for your child I think it's
okay like I don't think it's too hard to
to be thinkable you think everything's
gonna be alright everything's gonna be
fine yeah me too
I'm happy for her but it's like this is
where I want to know like legality like
who has more money I think he does just
cuz she's newer new they're both pretty
new me um amigos has been around for him
like a hot minute yeah and it's like so
she's more famous for sure but he's been
around longer and I think their group
has more of like I don't know I'm just
carry it's like today share everything
and just split it up like because they
know how to bourse works but how does
celebrity divorces work and how does
work in California where everything is
community property Chuy you just have to
hope
other persons on Masshole which is so
hard especially in California where
everyone is a big hairy bleached [ __ ]
but I don't think Hardy B is an [ __ ]
and I think that her man's cool
I think her man school too and I think
you know what I think I think he's a lot
of respect for her I mean how could you
not wait I can't believe cardi B you
didn't perform at the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show now that I'm thinking about
it like this was the year of cardi B she
probably was like you [ __ ] aren't
into ya know by the way for sure
[ __ ] love her there was someone else I
was thinking about and I was surprised
that they didn't perform at the port
Victoria's Secret Show I won't remember
but Marin Laura's the middle no you can
t gay why don't you Jesse me and the
minnow mm-hmm go back to sleep precious
gem of man he doesn't even know he has a
cousin coming
he better enjoy this time while he's
where he's ya know ever tells him yeah
she could talk times up tight I wish you
could talk maybe you don't what this is
what he would say hey what was that
linked for EM Jimmy I want Italian
luxury sold the maid the old way sold
the new way and Jimmy calm sighs shows
for 1500 girlie toad honestly he needs
the $50 off his off quarter well cuz
he's so broke you couldn't even come to
my show last night have funny rude so so
rude my foots asleep
next up Kim Kardashian reveals the quote
dramatic reason their family Christmas
Card tradition is over honest all equals
less you were so [ __ ] treacherous
enews caught up with the makeup guru at
the kkw beauty pop-up shop in the South
Coast Plaza Mall where she dished on the
family holic holiday card and mother
little Sicily Kardashian's well she's
just show the family Holocaust I almost
went there almost
I said challah card you almost did but I
did she asked when asked when whether
Chloe will be with the rest of the
Kardashians on Christmas
first and foremost the reality star got
down to the reasons why the
kardashian-jenner clan decided to forego
the highly anticipated photo shoot it
appears that after last year's drama the
family felt they no longer had it in
them to coordinate a card that would top
the masterpiece from last year
oh please st news this word of quote I
have to say and thanks to last year's
Christmas card that really did just [ __ ]
us over that was just so dramatic too
dramatic
I mean it spawned the fight where she
was the least interesting to look that
crazy I read this headline in two
seconds this morning and I thought it
said that they're not gonna have their
holiday party no I think Christmas yeah
but which I was like that is a truth
staple of I mean I'm not a part of it
but of society no it is I mean it's a
true staple of Instagram I think it's
best that they don't have the holiday
card honestly I don't think it's been
that great ever since they had like
robbing it
Caitlyn in it Lamar like I loved when
they had in the house and or when they
did that David LaChapelle yeah that's
what I was gonna say like no he's a Dave
Chappelle by the way yes to be confused
because it's very confused I was about
to google his name because I was about
to get it wrong David LaChapelle yeah I
know it's like Dave Chappelle
moonlighting this award-winning
photographer yeah we need that guy back
I'm down for Jessica actually no I would
love everyone kids included actually we
really do need a Christmas card like
with all the kids there over just the
tears that's what they should do that
would be really is it really not hard to
get them all in the same room for one
hour no they feel nuts Kardashians all
the time do you wait you guys just won
no I'm but by the way if it's causing a
lot of strife between the ladies I can
live without it we're at the Christmas
party set up for it a right taking the
photo there and post it on Christmas
where is Rob like seriously I've heard
that he's like I've lost a bunch waiting
he's gonna make like this big reveal I
mean I hope to god that's the truth that
would be I would be here for that I just
I think it's like we're over it also I
think we all are in agreement that his
wakes not even the problem anymore no
not at all it's like even as he lost
weight like then he has a new whole new
set of problems
totally but I was talking about this
with someone last night I don't remember
who it's like let's not forget like the
downfall of Rob Kardashian really came
on the heels of Rita Ora another reason
to dislike read Ora write except I do
kind of ship them and I think that she
could get him back to where he needs to
me well so when she first popped on the
scene with her Madonna haircut and her
red lipstick with like most gorgeous
like complexion I was like yes we Dora
and I didn't really care that she was a
talent act but then she just like out so
famous for truly doing nothing that now
I'm annoyed he's like that's what I want
to happen to me
I want to wake up and be so famous and
revered for an art that I haven't
contributed anything to maybe one day
with
be your chance also what's so crazy
about Robin we haven't spoken about this
is that Chris had to buy Arthur George
leave the company yeah because he
couldn't it was gonna go out of business
so she bought it she now owns it she's
been doing promotion bartering is
granting her promoting it so much oh my
god so nice that she's like supporting
her son's business she had to buy it
why don't they just let it go honestly
it's really not a bad business like it's
kind of cool I remember they sold Arthur
George at the Colgate bookstore which is
seller gazing Marcus and I can't think
of a different like fun luxury sock
brand I couldn't either
and he there he have a business like I
can't what the hell does he do all day I
don't know like sleeps and sips like
purple it sounds so fun not the perk I I
don't know about purple but that's what
I read I do okay speaking of things that
you read sophie turner calls out
publications saying nick jonas his
marriage to Priyanka is quote fraudulent
now I saw this headline this morning as
I was leaving my apartment
it was just Jared posted an Instagram
with this that sophie Turner called out
a pub with a publication for calling the
marriage quote fraudulent and I was like
oh my god is it us like who did she call
out oh my because Warren is a word that
we use we definitely call their marriage
fraudulent on Instagram I don't know
that we're a publication but maybe we
are but maybe we could be they really
click the link it's not loading I don't
like scrolling scrolling scrolling thank
God it's not us she's calling out the
cut but and it's I don't think that
articles mentions that Joe Jonas calls
it out too he tweeted something as well
if you want me to find it let me know
I'll find it okay um but Sophie
basically read quote tweeted the cuts
story that asking if their marriage is
frozen and she said this is wildly
inappropriate and totally discussing
very disappointed that the cut would
give anyone a platform to spew such
[ __ ] ooh and then Joe Jonas
responded to the same tweet just being
like and he also capitalized something
weirdly that I wanted to ask her opinion
on okay let me know if you find the
tweet um give me a minute Joe Jonas
tweet you just go - I mean just hear I'm
sorry I'm being grandmother you're using
the microwave like I'm literally I'm
gonna start taking pictures with my iPad
I'm gonna do it to make sure me
everything's gonna be take a picture of
you nothing
funnier okay I got it Joe Jonas precious
gem is precious gem
taking a precious and jemmye is precious
gem and licking something honestly if
this is if this is how he wants to go
down let them two can play that game
okay I'm not gonna be able to find this
sweet okay I got it
okay um here he said this is disgusting
at the cut you should be ashamed of
to have someone write such evil words
what Nick and pre have is beautiful love
thank you next he capitalized through
the B and L what Nichkhun pre have is
capital B beautiful capital L love is
that a song it's pretty capitalization
right yeah I don't know that's weird
just a thought um okay so Theo what
stash of napkins are you pulling from
okay you must be a privileged John issue
box oh there is this stop pick him back
up yeah he was being a precious gem he
was being a precious MJ I made that joke
before Betty where in living I'm so
sorry um it's fine anyways so this
article by the way and I read it this
morning at the bottom it said this post
has been updated which means that they
had to take out some of the meaner
meaner stuff and also it sounded a lot
like the girl watch the chest because
she was referencing watch happens live
when he said that he has been linked to
Kate Hudson and he confirmed that and
that he loves an older woman because
they know what they want
oh yeah them coming out how do you think
the girl has oh my god the biggest pet
of all time and I'm just so happy it
wasn't I know but she also has like the
cut New York Magazine to fall back on
you know she's like a reputable
journalist right so it's like it's
better that she they they came for her
and not for us oh my god of course like
she write like she has health insurance
we don't we can't afford to take any
more losses here at the morning do can't
afford to like get our heart rates
no no truly like I will die and I will
be the go to the hospital Mike I don't
have insurance
I spent all my money on a dress for the
points guy Awards and a spray tan and I
hurt my eyebrows where pairs of shoes
and four pairs of my son but I got $50
from MGM e.com / toast okay are you
ready for the fifth and final story
that's mmm I really am this is so hunger
that's a follow-up to a story that we've
been following Netflix reportedly paid a
hundred million dollars to keep friends
for another year after fan up or started
by girl with no job okay thank you
because I just wanted some credit and
you are the fan you know who's only the
only person out here giving me credit
Jax Taylor he tweeted me thank you
no Jax Taylor because that you know they
they think that they're the modern
friends cast so they're like so attached
to the show okay I'm gonna head dodge
them in that theater he never talked
about the vote Vanderpump real thing we
didn't because it was the most
horrifying thing I've ever talked about
and I'm really upset because every time
vogue like gets in tune with something
they ruin it like so now that they're on
to Vanderpump rules like does that mean
it's been affirmed proces over because
of Oguz like now finally catching on
like the weenies of the world watch it
and they couldn't stop like keeping up
the comparison to friends like right
because they were watching friends right
and as I guess and they are friends but
it's not the modern day friends like
people who watch friends and Vanderpump
rules like it's not all the same people
know and like their that articles like
affinity with friends was like silly in
the movie his affinity with the Hudson a
hundred percent said it it's like no and
it's it's like it's forced artistry and
there's a natural-born Talent artist
myself I hate when you have to fight for
that kind of creative you know I agree
what are you drinking in that cup iced
coffee
I think Theo wants them he's can I have
a little set sure I'm just getting dry
mouth because I'm talking so much about
all my favorite topics pop culture
related you can finish it cuz that would
be my that's my second coffee are you
all jittery show me your hand I see what
it's delicious coffee oh enjoy I can't I
grieve later it's the best what was the
story 100 million dollars is friends
worth on your point out here's this is
the thing I mean if you if you read the
blinds what empty says about Netflix is
that they are going down and honestly I
do think it was worth 100 million
dollars because myself I mean I don't
have a Netflix account that I paid for I
piggyback off of our families but there
are a lot of people oh by the way you
pay for that's how flicks is supposed to
be used
yes but there are a lot of people who I
read comments that agreed with me
wholeheartedly saying that like if this
really leaves I will cancel and I really
only watch Netflix these days to watch
friends like as bad
when I'm doing my hair so yes I do think
it was worth 100 mil think about it how
much they charge a month $11 and I think
we tried to do this math once before
they have over a hundred million users
so that's like add a billion that's like
a day's revenue yeah I gotta flex if you
think about it that way I guess and how
does Theo feel about friends leaving and
coming back well you know it's a show
that really relaxes me and when my mom
occasionally has to leave me at home
alone she puts it on me so I can go to
sleep and fall asleep play so I'm really
happy Rachel Green and Chandler Bing
will not be leaving my sets says Theo
Wow in an official statement of the
morning toast
Wow no one gets that precious man this
is such a delicious coffee I'm like I
don't even like coffee and I'll make it
for you every day and make it here no
I'm really not in the mood I've been
taking milk thistle so my bowels are
very regular and I just feel like coffee
[ __ ] that up no coffee helps that I
know but like an explosive way you know
okay and in the words of Theo
everything's gonna be alright
everything's gonna be okay gonna be good
I'm just like a bebe Rexha [ __ ] nut
job now yeah and that ass it's so real
yeah
it is so real I just love her luck and
her spirit I love her spirit it's really
crazy that Spirit Airlines wasn't
nominated for anything last night and
they didn't win like as a write-in
candidate either they should have
they're like when's the TVG Awards
because the Razzies for travel totally
and we have to host that because I'm
[ __ ] flight attendant from LaGuardia
who made me check my bag even though the
bins were the biggest bins I've ever
seen she gets the war the Lifetime
Achievement Award
I don't know Vanguard after tbg came on
here yesterday and was talking about
like the gate agents and and just how
hard they're how hard they work for very
little pay I need to like stop being so
angry no I agree except I will never not
be angry at that woman because she
singled me out and bullied me because I
was Jewish no no but I love to heard
about like they just deserve a more
positive attitude if you're on the
podcast and you're like what's that
sound I'm kissing my son so back off
honestly I love him so much he's been
such a good boy this episode he's been
90 percent good boy 10 percent this is
really growing up not 10 percent it was
5 percent that little tissue gate and it
wasn't his fault there's literally
full box of shoes right there that's
where he kept getting it from maybe he's
sad or he needs to blow his nose do you
think the illness and he talks on our
baskets oh for sure I think that he
wants to add let me see oh I think that
he wants to add George HW Bush's dog
Sully Oh to the bag to the basket of
people we wish good things for what do
you think I got a new deodorant by the
way because didn't I told you like my
body has changed and you order it no
longer works on my skin no I become
immune to deodorant I don't know what
that is so now I have a brand new Gio
Durant and a brand new toothbrush and I
feel like I really am like out here
smelling good right now hopefully I
don't know but like and by the way
whether you have the burst toothbrush -
yeah you know what I started doing
because they okay bursar all care is a
new toothbrush that we got and I love it
because it has disposable tops so every
three months ascription you get a new
top everything once and I've always been
an advocate like in my own world of
disposable toothbrushes because it's so
gross Jackie so I've been using this is
Jean when you're sick and you brush your
teeth and then this later you're not
sick and you're still using that
toothbrush head like excuse me so I've
been using the old ones to clean my
rings so I've been putting what I do is
I put my ring in a little cup with
Windex a little dish soap and warm water
and I let it soak for a while and then I
want to have the solution you know get
in the ring so I take my and it splashes
me this tub sometimes because it's so
powerful but I take my old burst oral
care brushes and I've been using that to
clean my diamond rings that's really
smart
I should you get to go to burst oral
care calm to get your limited rose gold
burst sonic toothbrush and use our code
toast at checkout to get 10% off your
order
that's burst oral care comm with code
toast for 10% off don't miss out on this
special offer go to burst oral care comm
today and don't forget to enter our code
toast for 10% off the new rose gold
toothbrush the toothbrush is really
pretty I'm rose gold everything it's
super toasty it is super toasty and I do
need a [ __ ] burst all carry your
breath
oh don't shame him no honestly I love
the O's breath but like sometimes after
he just slept for 30 minutes on my lap
so like when he wakes up from a nap
look just like a human it is ripe a
that's crazy that humans pressure
twice a day and we don't brush doggie
teeth you're supposed to be you're
supposed to brush it every day and it's
really bad for essential health and he's
probably brush his teeth five times in
his life just like his mom he's teeth
are rotten the element take care of it
don't worry don't worry I always take
care of you to make best health care in
the biz right here they need to make
personal care for dogs I will take them
who's your old toothbrush it's 11:11
Make A Wish Network show Network show
Network show Network show Network show
Network show Network so I chose a we're
getting closer
we are getting out there at all but
we're almost there yeah we're taking the
necessary steps the necessary things we
should enjoy this setup all we have it
have you guys gotten your tickets you
always show up looking like this no I
was thinking I'm like I just see the
network show so I can roll out of bed
and then have other people do my hair
and makeup and like my wardrobe that's
for sure and then haven't stopped buying
clothes just to wear them once I need to
make sure everyone's gotten their camcos
tickets yet because I know that we're
almost at capacity and I just I don't
know how many times to say it I can't
wait I can't wait are we gonna bring
tags so it's like the grounds are so
beautiful but he would need a full-time
nanny and unless any of the cam toasters
are up for the job let us know the link
to my cam to his tickets is at the bio
in our Instagram profile if you missed
the episode with the points guy
yesterday he did a bunch of credit card
recommendations and he put together a
thing on his website literally just for
toasters I felt so special and we met
the toaster last night who won the two
tickets to the TPG Awards Dana kabylia
and she was so cute she was so fun her
boy from the center - he was so cute
and it was so great she was like she
wanted it so bad and she got it I'm
really happy for her
Wow full circle Lincoln bio for Campos
tickets the password to the Eventbrite
is all caps can't and shan't no
apostrophes get your oh my god someone
emailed me asking for the password and I
gave him the wrong password would you
say premium yeah okay they'll figure it
out okay that it's wrong okay or they
like think they are spelling it wrong I
don't know actually respond to and
enchant um and we'll see there we're so
excited we hope everyone has a great day
tomorrow we are back with Heather
McMahon
and I'm not sure yet the chief in me on
the whole show he's gonna meet the three
of us I'm gonna put her in the middle so
I can moderate over here ya know we
honestly like tomorrow is like a day off
for us because Heather's gonna do all
the work are you gonna go to Lord and
Taylor so Heather and I have like a trip
planned because they're closing Lord and
Taylor and I didn't realize they learned
from me that she loves it just as much
as me and we were talking about it last
night and she was being so if I think so
yes we're gonna go even though she said
she went recently like 20 months ago and
it was really decrepit because they
haven't ordered new inventories and say
that so we're going out of business over
a year ago wow that's really sad but in
more happier news I will be going with
them and filming a video for behind the
scenes patreon episode cuz that'll be
funny as [ __ ] it really if it is
decrepit ladies and gentlemen it has
been an honor a privilege and a blessing
spending this morning with you I hope
you enjoyed it I'm sorry that you have
to go back to the work place but like go
hang out with Sally at the water cooler
get a snack get a steak whatever it is
love you so much we'll see you tomorrow
you